[Musique]
changer le monde
vaste programme je rêve de l'humanité
certains vous diront que c'est une
utopie irréaliste mais d'autres pensent
que c'est un espoir possible pour
l'humanité est alors en fait pour
changer le monde
eh bien peut-être que la meilleure
manière ça serait peut-être de voir si
déjà l'humanité a réussi à faire des
changements positifs déjà dans les
années passées dans les décennies
passées et bien je vous propose ce soir
de partager avec vous un certain nombre
d'informations peu connu mais me
semble-t-il fondamental est qu'ils
permettent de d'avoir de l'espoir
aujourd'hui pour demain prenons par
exemple l'extrême pauvreté dans les pays
en développement et bien au cours des
dernières décennies
elle a radicalement baissé de façon très
importante
il y a une trentaine d'années environ la
moitié des personnes vivant dans les
pays du sud et bien été dans cette
situation d'extrême pauvreté
eh bien ça a énormément baissé en
quelques décennies un autre thème proche
la faim dans le monde
là aussi chute radicale de la faim dans
le monde
au point que pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité on peut espérer
voir la fin de la faim dans les
décennies à venir d'ici 2030 2030 c'est
demain alors il ya aussi des problèmes
tels que bien sûr les médias nous
parlent beaucoup de la guerre certes les
médias en parlent beaucoup mais je crois
qu'il est important de contextualiser ça
dans une vision plus large
prenons par exemple ce qui s'est passé
depuis disons le début du siècle est
bien passé on voit que l'essentiel des
morts par guerre et bien ça a été
pendant les deux guerres mondiales mais
aujourd'hui c'est un film alors bien
entendu je n'ai pas nier la réalité des
choses
chaque guerre est un drame chaque mort
par guerre est un drame humain
mais tout de même aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup moins de morts pour une raison
très simple c'est que les guerres notre
foi étaient des guerres internationale
entre l'état voire des guerres mondiales
et la mortalité se chiffraient en
centaines de milliers de personnes en
millions de personnes aujourd'hui ces
guerres internationales ont quasiment
disparu de la surface de la terre il ya
encore très peu et c'est les guerres
civiles c'est par milliers de personnes
bien sûr encore une fois c'est un drame
mais c'est 100 fois moins voire 1000
fois moins et si on regarde
ne serait-ce que depuis 1946 eh bien
vous voyez que la même là la courbe elle
est très fortement halladay à la baisse
et il ya une remontée depuis quelques
années dues essentiellement la guerre en
syrie mais c'est un bib par rapport à ce
qui pouvait y avoir dans d'autres
décennies
autre problème me direz vous le
terrorisme est certes je ne vais pas
nier aussi ce problème majeur qu'est le
terrorisme et en particulier l'année
2015 en france qui a été vraiment
problématique dramatique mais là aussi
j'aimerais contextualiser d'une manière
plus large
cette année si dramatique et bien la
même année il ya eu près près de 4000
morts par accidents de la route
il ya eu environ dix mille morts par
suicide
il eût pile plus de 70 mille morts en
raison du tabac et cette année là il ya
eu 149 morts par les attentats alors me
direz-vous mais il faut pas comparer
l'incomparable ça n'a rien à voir certes
mais ce que j'aurais surtout souligner
c'est que à la suite de cette vague
d'attentats et bien beaucoup de gens
avaient peur de sortir
ils n'osaient plus sortir mais si on ne
sort plus pour les attentats on ne peut
plus sortir pour rien il faut rester à
la maison et même à la maison les
accidents domestiques tuent plus que les
attentats et surtout et surtout il faut
savoir que ce que visent les terroristes
ci visaient des cibles stratégiques il
attaquerait je sais pas un ministère
je ne sais aux autres mais il vise à
toucher la population ce qui vise ce que
visent les terroristes et à terroriser
la population et la meilleure réponse
que nous pouvons leur donner leur poser
même et bien c'est de refuser d'entrer
dans cette spirale de la peur
autre élément de contextualisations qui
me semble très important les médias
évidemment nous parle de dèche les
médias nous parlent d'al qaïda mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que
régulièrement des organisations
terroristes et bien arrêtent leur
activité
prenons quelques exemples récents et ce
ne sont pas les seuls voici en irlande
en espagne en france en colombie
alors il n'y a pas que les problèmes
sociaux il y a aussi la criminalité
petite question au passage à votre avis
de combien à augmenter la criminalité au
cours des dernières décennies en
occident
réfléchissez un petit peu et bien en
fait le geste que j'ai rien faire est
erroné parce que le sens c'est comme ça
la criminalité en occident a
radicalement baissé ces dernières
décennies est de même dans un certain
nombre de pays du sud
prenons comme exemple la france et plus
particulièrement l'île de france avec
des chiffres très précis par l'institut
médico-légal de paris on peut pas
trafiqué les ces chiffres très bien la
criminalité a été divisé par trois en
vingt ans comment se fait-il alors que
nous pensons si fort souvent que la
criminalité augmente
peut-être que la réponse se trouve dans
les médias la place des faits divers et
en particulier des crimes dans les
médias a triplé en quinze ans et c'est
pour ça que nous pensons que la
criminalité augmente alors qu'en fait
elles diminuent
passons maintenant à l'environnement la
couche d'ozone
alors la couche d'ozone c'est un vrai
problème parce que cette couche qui
s'effiloche et qui ne nous protège plus
eh bien on nous ont prédit des cancers
par millions sur la surface de la terre
mais j'y pense
avez vous remarqué que depuis quelques
années les médias nous parlent
pratiquement plus de l'ozone ah bah
c'est parce que le problème est en train
d'être réglés vous le problème c'est que
les médias nous parlent quand il ya des
problèmes et ne nous parle plus quand
les problèmes sont en train de se régler
ou quand ils ont disparu et bien comme
avec 8 milliards d'habitants sur terre
il ya forcément des problèmes
écologiques sociaux quelque part et on
est uniquement il demandait de ces
problèmes allons l'ozone c'est très
intéressant parce que aujourd'hui
comparativement à ce qui se faisait il
ya 30 ans eh bien les industriels ne
produisent presque plus de substances
détruisant le zone et la population la
société non consomme pratiquement plus
résultat la couche d'ozone se reforme et
elle sera entièrement reformé en 2050 et
peut-être même avant c'est intéressant
de savoir cela mais c'est encore plus
intéressant de comprendre comment ça
c'est fait et bien le processus a été un
homme mostafa tolba directeur de l'
agence de l'onu pour l'environnement et
qui à la suite d' alerte qui avaient été
faites par des savants sur le problème
de la couche d'ozone et bien a réussi à
réunir autour de la table et bien des
ennemis des adversaires farouches en
tout cas qui était notamment des
militants environnementalistes des
industriels est par ailleurs également
des ministres de l'environnement d'un
certain nombre de pays du monde
et bien c'est lorsque ces trois parties
travaillent ensemble en quelque sorte
l'état la société civile et le marché
qu'on peut le mieux résoudre les
problèmes et bien effectivement il a
réussi à ce que d'anciens adversaires
deviennent des partenaires et travailler
ensemble chacun avec sa responsabilité
on a résolu le problème de la couche
d'ozone
c'est exactement le même processus qui
s'est passé avec la dépollution du rhin
alors le rhin c'est un jeu vous donne là
une image bucolique mais c'est pas que
ça le rhin c'est aussi ça la plus grosse
concentration mondiales d'industries
pétrochimiques et sidérurgiques
il y a trente ans le rhin était un
cloaque à ciel ouvert le fleuve le plus
pollué d'europe et l'un des plus
polluées au monde
aujourd'hui on peut se baigner dans le
rhin depuis la source jusqu'à
l'embouchure et comment ça c'est fait et
bien de la même manière une ministre de
l'environnement d'un pays du nord de
l'europe et bien rassembler ces trois
partis dont je viens de parler les
industriels les militants écolos et des
ministres de l'environnement et c'est ça
qui a permis ensemble d'essayer de
trouver des solutions
alors il ya dans l'environnement il n'y
a pas que la pollution n'y a pas que
l'ozone il y a aussi la biodiversité et
je suis tout à fait lucide tout à fait
conscient que s'il ya des vrais
problèmes notamment je pense comme ça
comme espèce le lieu les lions les
éléphants et d'autre mais c'est
important aussi de savoir qu'il y à des
réussites c'est important de savoir
qu'il y à des résultats positifs
prenons par exemple la surface des parcs
naturels des réserves dans le monde
elle a pratiquement doublé chaque
décennie ici c'est les chiffres qui sont
ici c'est en millions de kilomètres
carrés eh bien il ya de plus en plus de
réserves aujourd'hui qu'il ya 10 ans 20
ans ou 30 ans en termes d'espèces un
certain nombre d'espèces diminue mais un
certain nombre d'espèces se développent
et vont mieux
prenons un animal tel que la baleine à
bosse qui est absolument magnifique
en particulier avec ces sauts hors de
l'eau eh bien il ya une cinquantaine
d'années de la population des baleines à
bosse était vraiment préoccupant
aujourd'hui elle se porte très bien
plus impressionnant encore le bison
d'amérique
le bison d'amérique est lui passé au
bord de l'extinction
il y a un siècle aujourd'hui la
population est florissante
le bison d'amérique se portent très très
bien et en france d'ailleurs nous avons
aussi d'autres espèces qui étaient en
voie de disparition il ya quelques
années et qui se porte bien aujourd'hui
je prends par exemple
l'aigle royal le castor le bouquetin et
prenant une espèce emblématique
la cigogne la cigogne blanche elle aussi
en france est vraiment passé au bord de
la disparition il ya 40 ans il y avait
pratiquement plus de cigognes en france
aujourd'hui il ya des cigognes
quand en quantité bien plus importante
et d'ailleurs au point qu' on ne peut
plus parler aujourd'hui de cigogne
d'alsace
la cigogne s'est répandu dans toute la
france devant toutes ces résultats qui
existent qui sont déjà là quelles sont
les clés de ce succès parce que
finalement ce qui est important si on
veut améliorer la situation de demain la
meilleure manière c'est pas seulement de
se lamenter sur les problèmes qui
existent encore c'est d'essayer de voir
comment on peut les résoudre
parce que je suis lucide il y a certes
deux milliards de personnes qui sont
sorties de la faim en 20 ans mais il en
reste encore 800 millions il y as her
l'ozone qui est en partie réglé
maintenant mais il y a le réchauffement
climatique et donc il est utile et
nécessaire même de s'inspirer des
réussites pour pouvoir en les remuant
type lié demain et comme clé de la
réussite
et bien je vous propose ces données là
tout d'abord nous avons besoin de
personne inspirante des personnes qui
nous donne de l'optimisme et de l'espoir
parce que si nous regardons portons un
regard désespéré sur le monde et sur la
planète et ben y'a plus rien à faire on
baisse les bras et on attend que la
catastrophe finale mais par contre si on
a des personnes aspirante qui nous est
bien nous pourrons avancer
mais bien sûr ce n'est pas seulement un
enjeu d'individus
c'est aussi un enjeu d'action collective
et on sait que pour un certain nombre de
problèmes majeurs tels que le paludisme
ou tel que la sauvegarde des forêts
divers
éléments et bien on sait que ce qui est
le plus efficace et d action
communautaire de terrain qui est des
gens qui travaillent ensemble qui
s'engagent ensemble mais oui si ça n'est
pas suffisant il faut aussi qu'ils aient
des décisions au plus haut niveau et
donc des chefs d'état des responsables
politiques et bien s'engage il leur faut
d'une part du courage parce que pour
certaines décisions parfois il faut
aller contre la tendance normale et je
prends un exemple de plus en plus de
pays ont aboli la peine de mort
mais bien évidemment il faut du courage
lorsqu'un décideurs politiques
responsables et bien s'engage dans ce
sens il en faut également de l'humilité
parce que ils peuvent pas faire tout
tout seul et je reviens à ce que je
disais il ya quelques instants
il est nécessaire d'instaurer des
partenariats d'instaurer des
partenariats avec la société civile la
sauce d'instaurer des partenariats avec
les entreprises et c'est ça qui est le
plus efficace pour améliorer la
situation du monde
il est nécessaire aussi d'avoir une
valeur centrale qui est la persévérance
parce que les opinions publiques évolué
mais ça met du temps mais quand même on
a des éléments qui montrent qu' il ya de
l'évolution je prends par exemple la
peine de mort les guerres la pollution
eh bien c'était des thèmes qui
paraissait normal voire un nécessaire il
y à quelques décennies et aujourd'hui ça
devient de plus en plus inacceptable
dans la population ne nous pourrons
avancer que si li a effectivement une
évolution des mentalités et pour cela
dernier élément important me semble-t-il
le rôle des médias parce que les médias
modifie notre regard sur le monde
peut-être que certains d'entre vous avez
une vision très négative du monde avant
de venir peut-être vous l'avez toujours
mais il se pourrait que ce que je viens
de dire ce soir dont les médias parlent
peu et qui me semble fondamental et bien
et vous ne le saviez pas et donc notre
regard sur le monde et aussi modifié par
les médias or or il faut bien
reconnaître que la vision des médias est
assez anxiogène
ça nous booste plutôt désespoir mais
depuis un certain temps et bien des
journalistes ont compris que à côté du
journalisme de
problème il est nécessaire de développer
un journalisme de solutions parce que si
on veut changer le monde est bien aussi
il faut nous présenter les bonnes
nouvelles
et si vous prenez par exemple le libellé
solutions qui est un numéro une fois par
an que libé publie et bien qui est
essentiellement rempli de d'expériences
positives
eh bien on fait comment dire c'est le
numéro le plus vendu de toute l'année
nettement au-dessus de la moyenne de
l'année ce qui prouve au passage que les
bonnes nouvelles peuvent se vendre
contrairement à ce que disent certains
il ya aussi une association par exemple
au porteur d'espoir qui fait du journal
de soluce de solutions est un site parc
nous et puis vous avez probablement un
certain nombre d'entre vous pour vu ce
film demain qui est également plein de
solutions et qui a fait un carton dans
les salles obscures avec très peu de
publicité essentiellement par le bouche
à oreille bon tout ça peut-être certains
d'entre vous se disent bon tout ça c'est
bien joli il est bien sympa le monsieur
là haut mais il a un peu des lunettes
roses
ils voient le monde voilà on rose quoi
la vie est belle tout va bien pas du
tout la question qui m'est souvent posée
c'est de me dire c'est bien joli vos
trucs mais il ya un problème majeur
le problème majeur c'est les autres
tout irait bien savait pas les autres et
ben moi je suis pas sûr que le problème
c'est les autres
moi j'ai l'impression que le problème
c'est cette phrase
le problème c'est penser que les
problèmes viennent des autres parce que
tant qu'on pense comme ça et bien on ne
fait pas nous même l'effort qu'il faut
et donc j'en arrive à la suite qui a
écrit ceci
vous savez dans la vie on a droit à
l'erreur c'est contrairement à ce qu'il
avait dit à l'école l'erreur n'est pas
une foot alors c'est nelson mandela
alors on peut pas dire que nelson
mandela était un doux naïve qui ne
connaît rien à la vie surtout je
voudrais souligner quelque chose c'est
que non même se demander la non
seulement il avait ses convictions
qu'ils avaient de la montée chez toute
personne y compris ses pires adversaires
mais surtout il en a fait une stratégie
politique parce qu'il faut pas rêver
quand mandela arrive au pouvoir il n'a
pas quand même une baguette magique dans
les mains qui détient les rênes des
ministères par exemple de la justice de
la police et de l'armée
sc les blancs et oui il ça change pas
tout du jour au lendemain et alors
imaginez que mandela leur dise oh vous
êtes tous des méchants
vous nous avez fait du mal pénale
pendant des dizaines d'années
allez foot ou aller en prison je suis
pas sûr qu'ils vont y aller il on y
allait de leur plein gré en revanche on
risque on aurait risqué dans ce cas là
d'avoir une guerre civile et un retour à
la case départ et peut-être encore pire
alors certes serbe
l'afrique du sud n'est pas un paradis
aujourd'hui mais les plus l'enfer
qu'elle a été et je pense qu'il est bon
de s'inspirer de l'exemple de mandela
parce que l'exemple de mandela c'est
précisément de comment dire de faire des
adversaires des partenaires alors certes
certes ne vont pas la carrure ne venons
pas la capacité de faire tout ce qu'il a
fait mais chacun d'entre nous petits
citoyens peut-être que notre manière
déjà de pouvoir changer le monde là où
nous sommes
et bien c'est peut-être justement de
commencer à parler avec les personnes
avec des personnes avec qui
apparemment nous n'avons rien à dire et
rien à partager je pense que c'est déjà
un premier pas et puis il ya d'autres
pas également tout simplement sur le
plan de l'environnement chacun a sa part
à apporter et ça peut être les
transports en commun d'utiliser utiliser
plus souvent que les voitures ça peut
être là comment dire le fait de manger
moins de viande parce qu'on sait qu'il
ya un effet direct sur la déforestation
de l'amazonie
par exemple dans l'univers professionnel
vous avez des par exemple dans
l'enseignement aujourd'hui des études
ont montré que l'apprentissage
coopératif est plus efficace que
l'apprentissage compétitif en termes
aussi bien de résultats scolaires que
d'ambiance dans la classe de bien-être
et estime de soi des élèves de respect
des enseignants un autre exemple ski de
professionnels dans le monde de la santé
et bien ceux des études ont également
montré que les les membres du personnel
médical infirmières médecins qui font
preuve d'empathie à l'égard des patients
et bien ça des effets non seulement sur
le bien-être psychologique du patient
mais également sur la santé physique et
donc j'ai envie de dire que face à
parfois l'obscurité du monde que nous
renvoient les médias eh bien peut-être
que d'avoir le sourire lumineux de
nelson mandela peut être une réponse
face à l'obscurité du monde que nous
renvoient les médias eh bien chacun
entre nous peut-être allumons notre
petite lumière
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui